durch nun mal da
durch die anrufe letzte chance
was bleibt von einem langen gemeinsamen
leben wenn eine krankheit die
erinnerungen stück für stück weg stiehlt
davon handelt dieser film
das ist für den ist symptom das immer
wieder eine platte ursprung hat das
gleiche wiederholte jetzt ist erstmal
muss ich werde jetzt mal aushalten aber
war man es auch irgendwann mal gästebuch
das nicht so grün sind deine ich noch
ein zweites mal mit gesichts vorantrieb
und nach ein feuchter mag ich sandra als
nachweis oder missverständnis stiegt für
den modus der concepta es ertragen
es ist november 2010 meine ersten
begegnungen mit den baum am netz
krankheit begann schleichend karl
baumann erzählt von ungewohnten
missverständnissen dass seine frau
plötzlich tischgespräche stürzte
jeden mittag nur noch bücher müssen vor
setzte
so war kam nicht überrascht als annett
vor drei jahren die alzheimer diagnose
bekam er ist heute 71 jahre alt 67 jeden
tag wenn kauf ein pferd pflegt ist sie
mit dabei kommt das alles das weniger
wichtig das ist dann so einfältig machen
karl sucht immer nach möglichkeiten an
et am alltag zu beteiligen
mannschaftsarbeit mit dem mittel und
umtrunk von carl f da nicht allein
spazieren ihren lieblings weg kennt ihn
noch immer er nimmt ein gewisses risiko
in kauf sagt aber lebensqualität zählen
eher als absolute sicherheit
was fehlt an etwas geht in ihr vor das
möchte auch hier man wissen das ist
schon irgendwie war die wahl und die
zugang zu leeren
er hat mir
ein halbes jahr später treffe ich die
baumanns im eigenen garten in diesem
haus hat das ehepaar vier kinder
großgezogen eine tochter drei söhne
wo früher primarlehrer ist seit elf
jahren pensioniert er weiß dass eine
krankheit unheilbar ist und langsam aber
stetig fortschreitet und habe gesagt
nein das macht mir will das stück nicht
und ich kann mir sagen ich weiß nicht
wie lange das gesagte schnell wie es
geht
also ich probiere die momente moment mit
der einigung mit freunden konnte mit
wind und das glaube ich ist das skore
seit jahrzehnten haben die baumann sein
segelboot auf dem zürichsee an dieser
tradition hält karl fest alles soll im
gewohnten umfeld leben fragt er
dafür sei eine familie da er betreut
seiner frau inzwischen rund um die uhr
toni krinner an eine ehrung durch sie
kommt wodurch sie ist 16 jahre werden
sich so dann habe ich mir den film
spielt ried das muss man ja heute zu 60
christa dabei ich spüre schöne frauen zu
füßen
ja an etwa kindergärtnerin diese
erinnerung ist ihr geblieben
ein weiteres halbes jahr ist vergangen
karl baumann begleitet seine frau zur
neurologin seit jahren kontrollierte und
spielt den verlauf von netz
demenzkrankheit ist auch musik stark
verändert und ihre
konzentrationsfähigkeit dir gott mehr um
weg bliebe bis nämlich das wird sie
haben da einfach du willst du haut
machen was macht schon unzählige weist
das nach pcs macht
nachdem ich schon sehr gut
jetzt soll eine uhr zeichnen der
standardtest steht jedes jahr an
er spiegelt den verlauf ihrer krankheit
die erste ausgezeichnet punk dass ich im
märz nun auch sie kann erklärt an der
hand sie das ganz perfekt gemacht 2011
da hat sie aufgeschrieben und den hammer
im dezember hat sie das ist so zeichnet
sie schönes muster gemacht und da sind
sie jetzt noch mit seht also das jetzt
im laufe von 2011 nicht leicht wie
schlecht der wortschatz abnimmt also
dass kameraden
[Musik]
wie blicke in ein vergangenes leben
die baumanns waren mal ein klassisches
ehepaar ihr berufstätig sie hausfrau für
die vier kinder dar
da waren aber auch gemeinsame hobbys der
austausch in alltäglichen dingen vor der
alzheimer-krankheit in ihrer
kommunikation ist nichts mehr wie früher
um khalid diskutiere mit dem namen für
bisher konnten antwort über vacando fc
basel ist das motto es geht alles haben
wir interessiert sich das ist die
einzige kommunikation das sind die
setzen sobald möglich probiert machen
ich möchte mich und das ist das wo
eigentlich für den partner
es freut mich dass es gegenüber hat
warum machen gar nicht zum grübeln und
das ist das ist noch schwierig das ist
weg und geht geld braucht ein gutes feld
wo die familie waren wir unterstützen
und man das ab und zu wieder haben
tragen will die situation untragbar
bis jetzt könnte sich kaum einen
einzigen freien tag pro woche
wenn annett eine tagesstätte besuchte
jetzt dabei ist ihr ziel die sonnweid
eine demenz klinik in wetzikon seit
neuestem bringt karl seine frau einmal
im monat in dieses spezial heim am netz
bleibt vier tage hier und vor allem sie
übernachtet auch das haben wir die der
familie besprochen und dann eine mini
kind trug dunkles jaffa tritt muss
einfach war weil ja und jetzt machen
muss
und ja das ist ein weiser entschluss sie
das gemacht hat
[Gelächter]
mein eindruck ist dass alex sich
durchaus wohl fühlt mit dieser lösung
und kann hat dann diesen tagen eine
echte pause sonst ist er allein für
annett verantwortlich ich werde mich in
der mutter kind analyse parat machen und
michael schrank hat eigentlich wieder
auf die ebene zu
und der ist natürlich so dass ja das
könnte die schufa über ein jahr vergeht
bis sich die baumann sieht adresse vor
kurzem feierte annett ihren siebzigsten
geburtstag
karl ist nun 74 jahre alt hinnehmen darf
die alzheimer-krankheit seine frau immer
mehr verändert jetzt sind neu
aggressionen also zum beispiel kupfer
comeback und sucht mit seiner frau fällt
kann überall auf eine taktik ist die
leute aufzuklären
[Musik]
mit dem schuhkauf ist wieder eine
situation mehr gemeistert doch daheim
geht es für karl pausenlos weiter
die lust auf süßes ist typisch für
alzheimerkranke auch das gefühl nicht
genug zu bekommen
doch eher an lukas zu bedienen war ich
vor ihm sind
der schaffte geburtstag überhaupt ja so
bestellt mit zum maßstab besorgen
sie nimmt auch zum kühlschrank omas ist
und zwar ganz unkontrolliert und dania
hohmann im logo ist nicht passiert ist
gerade den kuchen kommen situation mit
hochofen ich unter sich
ja aber es ist natürlich so dass kuchen
zu dass du nichts machen
so misst der frauen erster koch ja das
ist chrome ist das überhaupt so
abschließend dass sie mich war begründet
uniqlo was ich aber so viel korn
karl baumann ganz ungestört das hat
seinen grund seit kurzem lebt und
arbeitet katalin kovacs bei baumanns sie
nimmt karl den haushalt ab und hilft ihm
alles zu betreuen
ohne die hilfe würde ich das nicht
geschafft
das ist unmöglich die handwerker anträge
da nicht eines heims tour oder da ist zu
organisieren will
zu schwer wiegt 100 prozentig blockiert
sie da eine be am computer machen will
einfach nur eine plage frau baumann
akzeptiert die neue person in ihrer
küche noch nicht so richtig ihr mann
aber plant endlich wieder eine
ferienreise reisewelt die punkte
mitgenommen
auf ihren spaziergängen wird an ideen
zwischen stets von katzer begleitet
vorbei ist die lust auf lange runden und
der schritt ist schleppender geworden
ihren heimweg fans kaum noch allein
[Musik]
sechs monate später ist passiert was zu
befürchten war
auf einem spaziergang entfernt es sich
ja nicht unbemerkt von ihrer begleiterin
kann und katar suchten sie vergeben
jetzt wird an nicht auf dem posten
registriert denn niemand wusste wer sie
war sie selbst nicht und auch nicht die
unbekannten anwohner die an etwa sich
aufnahmen und die polizei alarmierten
was meinst du net hoffe dann ungeniert
bis 117 euro trennt sie jetzt da man
qualität perfekte minute cacau
und so hat sie ja eine hauptstruktur
meerane hauptstadt zu spüren
die das schöne woche das ist eine hoch
beruf macht und das schulungskurs diese
forschung der hand da sämtliche die
institution ob kabarett auch spitäler
wohnheim und zur weihnachtszeit im
moment keiner durch die weko das
tribunal privat betreut wird von ihrem
ehinger es stimmt karl ist inzwischen
enorm gefordert mit als betreuung obwohl
in katar unterstützt
für die heiklen bereich ist karl
zuständig verbreitet dass ich das mal
mist mache eigentlich sei das schlicht
aber etwas mit sarges ronny schmidt und
dann geht es zum prozess wo man sagt ja
dass monique uns darum entscheide dich
oder mach ich's nicht und darum mit
routine und ja also whisky personal euro
karl frey rückt näher und damit die
aussicht neue kraft zu tanken
damit wird den ganzen september in
demenz heim wohnen so lange war seine an
es noch nie in fremden händen
darüber macht sich so seine gedanken ich
meine hier zeigt sie waren sie machen
mich wie machen das ich und mache mich
heuer das nicht und zu wenig sport 1
monat solange das ist der hai auf wangs
begasse das meiste geld und das moniert
worden
paul sorgte lebe nicht gern allein an es
würde ihm fehlen
doch wenn die zeit da ist wird er sie
loslaufen
später erfahre ich als kauf- und seiner
galapagos reise heimkommt hat annett
zehn kilo zugenommen ihren karl aber
kennt sie noch immer